they'll probably hang you buddy
in the late 1800s America was evolving
on its way to becoming the most powerful
country in the world new immigrants
arrived thriving outposts became towns
and civilization was spreading rapidly
into the huge wild and lawless frontier
with Red Dead Redemption - Rockstar
Games aims to create a living world
that's not simply open but deeper more
interactive and detailed than ever
combining action storytelling and
gameplay in new ways as you live ride
and fight to survive as an outlaw in a
notorious gang as long as we get paid
you get shot I'm happy
the game is an attempt to capture this
pivotal moment when the age of outlaws
was ending and the modern world was born
there is a huge world to explore set
across a range of America's heartland
and frontier from harsh mountain trails
and dense forests to untamed swamplands
and sweeping deserts rugged livestock
towns to modernizing cities and much
more all populated with a diverse cast
of characters from turn-of-the-century
life now shoo please I'm waiting for
someone interesting to turn
you play as Arthur Morgan a trusted
senior gun in the vanderlin gay abandon
outlaws and outcasts on the run from the
pressures of civilized life once and for
all
[Music]
each time they're forced to flee an area
the gang sets of a camp as a base this
is where gang members eat sleep perform
chores play games and share stories
anyway country sheriff and he decided
for it these are the people
Arthur calls family and you'll get to
know each gang member over the course of
the game so you save the silly bastards
laugh and you and him go Robyn she
helping the camp with food and supplies
will keep morale high while spending
time with other gang members can reveal
new secrets fun things to do and
opportunities for mischief redistribute
some property in and out of camp the
world is alive and responds to the
player and your guns aren't the only way
to interact with the environment call
out to a passing Rider
talk yourself into trouble with a local
tough guy or out of trouble with a town
sheriff or intimidate a witness into
silence and more
you don't want to involve yourself with
this confrontations can be escalated or
diffused take it easy
you can form friendships or make enemies
as you choose your actions have
consequences and it's up to you to
decide just how honorable Arthur is
should I have killed you Jimmy Brooks
shooting and fighting have both been
radically improved to make combat deep
and engaging at all times each weapon
has unique characteristics with
realistic reload and recoil that always
keeps the player grounded and connected
to the action in a gunfight in a similar
way the bond with your horse is crucial
and changes based on your treatment of
the animal Oh some breeds are better
suited for certain tasks like this for a
while your saddle and saddlebags can
store extra weapons along with supplies
and animal carcasses that you pick up
while out roaming or hunting over time
the bond between you and your horse will
grow making them easier to control in
tense situations yeah he's a great horse
the devil's got him a rich and varied
ecosystem thrives in the world full of
predators prey and scavengers all smart
and sometimes deadly you wanna come with
me I'll show you
hunting helps the camp or earns you
money wound an animal and you'll have to
track them down animal pelts and other
items you find can be traded for cash to
use at general stores gunsmiths saloons
and elsewhere this is God's own country
and I feel I'm in purgatory this is a
world that is rich in depth and detail
all designed to be explored on horseback
or on foot as you live the fateful
journey of a gang of Outlaws on the run
across America
in the next gameplay video we'll look at
missions activities enemy gangs
robberies other things to do and much
more
including the evolution of sharpshooting
using the Deadeye system
[Music]